а прем'єр танцюють борис танки бруду
барбарис антифризи барбарис прем'єр
яценюк Борис добрий день про вибір
[музика]
з новим крові
добрий день а виборі день я всю
зарплату why do you in turin так 0
різне
в ad&d кулі на ногу лежить там
[музика]
я йду на ви
від ярма
гра ти
обертаємо вирішив будинок і ти
російською occupy the на острові
звірів гір
то змінити лийте 5 червня як крок
доброї волі збройні сили російської
федерації завершили виконання
поставлених завдань на острові змії на і
вивели тих, хто перебував там за кохання
замінені
гострий на мову зміїним чоловіки-тельці
тато далеку дорогу військовому кораблю h
kei начхати і сяо true to you
а
і
[музика]
а
дідусь вітає нова влада ти
мушу віддати нам все своє зерно напишу
бути
дідусь ну ви напевно ще не зрозуміли але
херсон таки русский ахуе до шукаю ничке
але це ви дарма владим
зазнають такої поведінки терпить джейса
вінджа перевернув слухайте я простягаю
вам жест доброї волі жах ти будеш
своїм лохом тули а я так і
подобу по-зміїному dead ти не розумієш
на кого прєш та народний байрактор
знижок ще та що ти несеш
дудинку спав я зрозумів дідуся йду на
висяка але старайся в ночі партизанськ
орсона прагнуть ручку сабудая козлів і я
станніс він прохорову
[музика]
добре я доповнив ви добре носити
вони садили за цю трубу обидва
пригальмуй-ка
щоб
а
неприємно якось коли тобі російській за
те, що російські чашку кави не можуть в
ресторані подати плюнуть обов'язково в
цю чашку є таким випадком
замовляєш каву чай російська російська
приносять туди
статі ресторану вже наплювали ось хлопців
вчора у литві
1245 покритий безглуздим часом
обстріляли що відомо про лобове
соціальних мережах далекобійники діляться
один з одним фотографіями розбитих
машинах та розповідями про зустрічі з
хуліганству ющ ими групами сергей
сухарів із ростова-на-дону каже що
тричі стикався з бандитами на
території євросоюзу
боротьба від молотки в руках щипці
ось так ось маша
[музика]
ми загони путіна звертаємося до тебе елон
маск
думки всі місця там у тебе щось не
виходить в Америці
так ось ми тобі пропонували приїхати в
росію у нас чудово космічна
галузь і дуже розвинена
забираємо всім свої документи забирали
все своє багатство, що ти там нажив
інакше в тебе його альберу і
приїжджай до нас у росію у нас будь-кого
[музика]
ost
the entire однаковий альпійський голова
сумка
самим полякам вогники у чіп трубі льоду
півста
мені подобається холодильник ай лайк
show you how sweet
lips міст годину після дати даулет гул
[музика]
дуру річ одна мить сьогодні ми на дно ви
все і уявляй перейшла з понтії здається
скаже різьбленням нададуть заарештували мені
ваще танків тракторист хочемо цим
принесли нагоді ми не шмат черствого
або на ньому це як раб очка їх муха
згорнула я говорю батька часу з гіпсу
смачне.
1 секунди я чую там так завагітніти та
а то б не будильнику ти за братом і
повну путівку 3 дні проплатив & батішта
і хто земний переход друзів то ніхто
навіть дівчатка там і чого ти носишся
інтерес політику ти просто все буде
мобілізації в Росії піде воювати
тоді, будь ласка, не забудь взяти з собою
пакет у
нас вже звідти не виробляє пакета вже
все закінчилось добре
все візьми собою ти поки що візьми
відмінно візьми для свого батальйону не
забудь про своїх друзів
[музика]
анька стали
великого не надто просто від Москви
до польської столиці всього 1300
кілометрів танк т-90 наприклад якщо не
вдаватися за допомогою транспортної авіації
піде в передмістя менше ніж через
добу після початку маршу
[сміх]
шукаю
[музика]
і
розповідає операцію сподіваюся на
криптоне біляк та випуск
чоловіки 50 озброювати і наздоганяв спершу
числа лавочка і закриваю ну жартую про
думаю він карає але нібито сховай його
сім'ю
нам по вітрина 3 взагалі думаю борту
наступного гачок з і
університет
[музика]
і
а
[музика]
алколіт з ізольдою з для дірки море а
перемог над їх futaba мій ал ал бити оу оу
оу оу біт
[музика]
ось такі 2 бій
світлі жити кит припаси нитка і
накладених манас деяких до п'ятого богота
покажемо це не так він
новинки маленький налагодив з анечкою та
будете балова high speed
нас часто на простих на колимі свами
шпалер. хочу в лазню твоїх очах серце
б'ється лише
[музика]
ласкаво просимо що likelihood та план
цей брус
[музика]
коротше не
знаючи куди я заїхав їдуть що за нас кірки
брати ебашить
тут на чорнобаївку
удостоїтися
заміняють їх shourouk рахунок нахуй не було
або що за
ух тиж
[оплески]
ти супер
[музика]
[ __ ]
він не кримінальний
вологи від нього геном
якась вологи тому вологи
я проект
некромант не було і немає не було генів на
твою першими
[музика]
одні було гелем і
україна enemy mine